Speaker 1: I want to kind of close the loop
on another one of these false allegations
of cancelation and businesses doing the wrong
thing. We talked at the top of the show about how
within sort of this reactionary framework of
fueling fear and getting people to abandon
critical thinking and rational thought.
One of the things that often happens
is that reactionaries will abandon their stated
principles. One such stated principle that we
followed on the right for a very long time is
basically businesses should be allowed to do
whatever they want if a business wants
to do something. If it's not illegal,
then that's it. It's just it's a business
decision, and we shouldn't be regulating that.
Of course, they abandoned this very quickly when
Twitter says, Hey, you know what? We don't want
anti-vax content on our platform. They quickly
say it's violating people's free speech. Twitter
should be regulated, but it's like, Well, hold
on a second. I thought you guys were the party
against regulating businesses. This started
to come up about a month ago when MyPillow CEO
and Trump suck up. Mike Lindell started
complaining, Hey, my bank wants to cancel me.
My bank is telling me they don't want my business
anymore due to what they're calling reputational
risk. Now, this is a very standard thing at
banks. Banks regularly assess their customers
and and ask questions like, Well, of course, do
we believe that this is a fraudulent business if
it is that they don't want to store assets, hold
assets for that business? But they also inquire or
think about reputational risk as our association
with this business or this individual potentially
going to damage our reputation. And if it is, they
could say, we don't want your business. It's a
perfectly reasonable decision that a bank can
make. MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell, also known to us
as Mike Pillow. A month ago started saying They're
trying to cancel me. They're doing the wrong
thing. This is crazy. They're silencing me all
these different things. And we said at the time,
they can do that. This is something banks
do. You're supposedly against regulation.
And now indeed, one of the banks that MyPillow
uses has cut ties with Mike Lindell. Business
Insider reporting that the Minnesota Bank and
Trust is terminating its business relationship
with Pillow. His accounts will be closed two
days from now and a month ago, as I told you,
the bank said that Lindell was a reputational
risk. Here is pillow on onward Steve Bannon.
And again, businesses making legal decisions,
which normally these right wingers love and
defend to the death. These we shouldn't regulate
them. Let them do what they want, get out of
their way. And yet here he is complaining.
Speaker 2: Tell us what happened today,
sir. Please, sir.
Speaker 5: Sir. Well,
I just got served the papers, either closing
my account papers and trust. That's Hartline
Heartland Financial Inc. Remember, we brought
it up a couple couple of weeks ago, and all of
you reached out to those two there to the bank
president staff at Minnesota Bank and Trust. And
I hadn't heard from, well, the cowards served this
paper. This paper on Friday afternoon after the
after the bills, the close of business.
Speaker 1: How dare they do it on a
Friday afternoon?
Speaker 5: They
didn't even bother to sign it.
Speaker 1: No, they didn't. They didn't.
So listen, having a bank account is not a
legal right. You have to apply to open one.
At one point I had a like a like a lock or a
freeze on my credit or something like that, and I
went to apply for a particular savings account and
they were like, Yeah, well, no, we can't do it.
And I was like, Wait, wait, hold on a sec. I
do. Oh, of course they have that risk, and it's
because I have this block on my credit. I don't
have a right to an account at any particular bank,
and they abandon their principles as soon as
it's inconvenient. Twitter ban someone. Well,
you should have a right to a Twitter account
and Twitter should be regulated. I thought
you guys were against that such regulation,
and when we talk about management reserves
the right to refuse service as long as it's
not illegal in the sense that they can't say,
we don't allow Christians to have bank accounts,
right? Pillow is a Christian or so, he says. If
they said we're not going to allow Christians to
have bank accounts, that would be against the law
if they said, we don't allow white people pillow
is white, we don't allow pillow to have a bank
account because he's white, that that would be
against the law. We don't allow pillow to have a
bank account because he was born in the United
States or because he's a man or because he's
heterosexual. That would be against the law.
But beyond that, there is a reason we say
management can refuse service to people because
they can make business decisions that. Are right
for them, and of course, the truth is, no
legitimate business should want anything to
do with MyPillow or Mike Lindell, and so there he
is, abandoning his own principles, how dare they?
How dare they do this? But of course
they are completely entitled to do it.